Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: Dr. Bright is no longer
allowed to offer the solution of "Use more
guns" to any problem!
Dr. Bright.
Look at me.
We went over this before, with the chainsaws.
Do you remember?
Do we really need to do this again?
I guess so.
We face a wide variety of problems here at
the Foundation, of varying degrees of severity.
There is no one-size-fits-all solution for
these problems, and even if there was, it
would not be "use more guns," or "get bigger
guns."
This includes but is not limited to: old-fashioned
dueling pistols, machine guns, or something
called the "octo-gun" which my notes say was
just eight guns taped together...?
How does that even work?
Never mind, don't answer that.
The point is, it's not helpful.
And Dr. Bright is not allowed in the armory.
Not even on his birthday.